[موسيقى]
اهلا وسهلا بكم في حلقه جديده من برنامجكم
الندوه صالونها اليوم يناقش مرور عام هذا
الشهر يصادف مرور عام على اندلاع الحرب
الروسيه الاوكرانيه او الاوكرانيه الروسيه
او الروسيه الغربيه او الروسيه العالميه
سميها ماشيه او الروسيه الصينيه ومن مع
هذا المحور ضد المحور الامريكي لكن ما
يهمنا في ندوه اليوم ليس مناقشه ابعاد هذه
الحرب واثارها على الاقتصاد العالمي الامن
الدولي العلاقات الدوليه صراع الاقطاب هذا
موضوع يبدو انه لا ساحل له لكن نحن نريد
ان نناقش امرا محدد المعالم واضح التضاريس
وهو
ما هو اثر هذه الحرب على
الجماعات بين قوسين الجهاديه نحن نعلم انه
تم محاوله استغلال هذه الحرب من بدايتها
لخلق بؤر جديده او لاسباب ربما سيشرحها
ضيوفنا حسنا اراها على هذا الامر قبل عام
ماذا عن اليوم هل صح الرهان او ما الذي صح
منه ومن الذي لم يصح لمناقشه او الدردشه
حول هذا الامر معي هنا في الرياض الاستاذ
الباحث اليمني نجيب غلاب الباحث اليمني
السياسي والكاتب المعروف ومن القاهره ايضا
الاستاذ ماهر فرغلي وهو باحث
معروف ايضا في مجال تتبع الحركات
الاسلاميه الجهاديه منها بوجه خاص وله
مزيد عنايه ايضا بموضوع اهتمام هذه
الحركات
بالساحه الروسيه الاوكرانيه والابداء معك
استاذ ماهر من القاهره كتبت حضرتك قبل عام
تحديدا في مارس مقاله او لا ليست مقاله
ورقه يعني عن هذا الامر وحاول تتبع ما
الذي ستفعله الحركات الجهاديه في
افغانستان من شتى الاطياف اول شيء عطنا
فكره ما الذي قلته قبل عام عن هذا الامر
بعد التحيه لسيادتك ولضيفك الكريم وللساده
المشاهدين انا كتبت عن الاسباب التي يمكن
ان تدفع
الحركات
الاسلاميه الى الذهاب الى اوكرانيا للقتال
في صف الاوكران او القتال في صف الروس
واستخدام هذه الحرب كابور التوتر جديدا
نحن نعلم ان القاعده استاذنا الفاضل لدى
هذه التنظيمات انهم يتواجدون في بيئه
التوتر في بيئه الفوضى وان لم توجد هذه
البيئه هم يصنعون بيئه التوتر لا وجود لهم
الا في بيئه التوتر ثم القاعده الثانيه
المهمه جدا وهي ان العمل لدى هذه
التنظيمات يسبق التنظيرات الفكريه يعني
انهم يقومون بالاعمال ثم يبحثون عن الدليل
الشرعي الذي يستندون اليه شرعيا وفكريا
يعني ليست الفكره سابقه ابدا العمل ومن ثم
هم
توقعت انهم سوف يستغلون هذه الحرب بدايه
لسابق تاريخهم
حرب عام 2014 حينما قاموا بتشكيل خليه حرب
القرد
نعم وحاولوا نستغلوا ذلك يعني اللي هم
الهاربين او السماويين من الشيشان
التي تناولت هذه الحرب في بدايتها اولا من
ناحيه السعاده والفرح باندلاع هذه الحرب
وثانيا
بالاستناد الى ما قاله ايمن الظواهري في
احد اصداراته بانه يجوز
المشاركه مع الكفار في حرب الكفار الاخرين
طالما ان ذلك ينهك الكافرين يعني يعني هذا
معنى كلام ايمن الظواهري في حديث سابق له
فالاستناد الى ذلك كتدليل على حاله الحرب
الاوكرانيه الروسيه في انه يجوز لكن اسمح
لي المفارقه تكمن في انه اوكرانيا تبع
المعسكر الامريكي وهم هؤلاء القوم
كانوا مرروا يعني اشتراكم في هذا الحرب لو
صح يعني بالقدر الذي يريدون او يرغبون
بانه جهاد في سبيل الله طيب الروس ضد
الامريكان فانتم في بعيدا عن اللغه
الدينيه اصبحتم في في المعسكر الامريكي
على هذه مصادفه ولا بريئه القصه يعني
اللي هي ليست مصادفه لكن هو في النهايه هم
لهم نحن نعلم ان هناك شعر مبيض مع الروس
داخل سوريا يعني واعتقد ان النكايه في
الروس في الحرب الاوكرانيه هي مهمه لدى
هذه الطائرات خاصه ان لدينا في سوريا وفق
احصائيات رسميه للامم المتحده من
اوزبكستان
وروسيا وشيشان وغيرها حوالي 4000
مقاتل موجودين حتى الان في تنظيمات كثيره
موجوده داخل سوريا منهم مثلا جندي الشمعه
واجناد القوقاز
ومعلوم عداواتهم لروسيا بسبب الوضع في
سوريا بسبب ايضا حرب الشيشان الاولى
وغيرها يعني وايضا يمكن لو نرجع للوراء
اكثر افغانستان لكن تظل امريكا بمنظور
الجماعات الجهاديه هي الشيطان الاكبر سواء
جامعات الجهاديه الشيعيه والسنيه وعلى ذكر
الشيطان الاكبر هل حاولت ايران استاذ نجيب
ايضا ان تدلي بدلويه ايران واتباع ايران
وجماعات ايران كما ادلى بدلوها الاتباع
الظواهري والقاعده وغيرهم هو نعم يعني
الايرانيين وكلائها بشكل عام هم انحازوا
بشكل كامل
لصالح روسيا
ولكن مساله بدفع مقاتلين انا اعتقد انه لم
يحدث لانه ايران صراعتها الحقيقيه هي في
المنطقه والدول العربيه لكن هم تبنوا فكره
تاييد روسيا لكن ايران مدت روسيا يعني
بالطيران مشير وفي بدايه الحرب كان هناك
حديث عن نقل بعض المقاتلين من سوريا الى
روسيا وايضا كان في احاديث كثيره عن مساله
ان يكون هناك يعني من وكلاء ايران يذهبوا
للقتال في روسيا لكن عمليا هذا الامر لم
يتم بالشكل المطروح لاسباب متعدده اولا
مثلها مثل حتى المجال المجال داخل المجال
الحركات الارهابيه كالقاعده السبب الرئيسي
انه اولا روسيا لا هي في حاله حرب مع
الاسلام السياسي بشكل او باخر وهي تخاف من
تنميتها في مناطق رغم علاقتها
بايران لكن هي ضد فكره الاسلام السياسي
وادارت معارك طويله يعني عندها وتخاف من
توظيفها في الصراع الا تحت مظله الدوله
الروسيه كما هو حاصل داخل الشيشه يعني
ورمضان
فقط هو تحت وايضا بعض القوه الاسلاميه بعض
المسلمين داخل الجيش الروسي وهم اقليات
لكن روسيا ايضا خايفه من مساله نمو
المعارضه من جديد وهي معارضه ضغط طابع
عنيف كما كان في الشيشان وفي القوقاز
والجمهوريات الاسلاميه وبالتالي هي لم
تراهن على هذه المساله المساله الاخرى هي
راهنت على مساله بعث الحاله القوميه
القوميه الروسيه والاعتماد عليها حتى
الموجات صحيح انهم اعلنوا الجهات يعني
وصدرت فتوى من الشيشان وانما يجب بعض
المفتين داخل الجمهوريه الاسلاميه انما
يجري هو جهاد في سبيل الله لحمايه
روسيا لكن هي لصالح فكره الدوله نفس
الكلام عند الغرب عندهم حذر ايضا في مساله
توظيف الاسلام السياسي حتى لا يتحول الى
اشكاليه لاحقا عندهم حذر لكن
حسب تتبع الاستاذ ماهر
وزير الخارجيه الاوكراني رحب في بدايه
الحرب بكل مقاتل متطوع لديه حساسيه ما
اتجاه روسيا يعني فتح الباب يعني لم لم لم
يستوقفه موضوع انه هذا فتح باب للجهاديين
يعني هو صحيح في هناك جهاديين موجودين لكن
اغلبهم هم من المعارضين
اللي هم في الجمهوريات الاسلاميه في
الجوجاج او اذا اغلبهم وهم مثل كتيبه
الشيخ منصور وايضا بعض المسلمين المسلمين
في القرد
موجوده ويقاتلوا لكن فاعليتهم ليست بهذيك
القوه صحيح انه وجع يعني
اوكرانيا وجه الدعوه عبر رئيسها للكل ان
ياتوا للقتال لكن يبدو لي انه الكثير من
الاطراف الاسلاميه بسبب استنزافها في
الحروب المتحده
كمل الجمله باستنز استنزافها وملاحقتها
وعدم وجود حاضن وداعم اساسي لها للذهاب
الى الى كرواتيا وايضا تخوفات الغرب
وركنوا على اليمين المتطرف الموجود في
الغرب في الحرب العالميه الاولى استاذ
ماهر يذكر التاريخ ان المانيا كانت او
الدوله العثمانيه كانت الى جانب المانيا
في الحرب العالميه الاولى
كان في وقتها في السلطان الخليفه يعني وان
كان بشكل شبه صوره لكن سلطه معنويه
الالمان طلبوا من السلطان ان يعلن الجهاد
في سبيل الله يعني في حرب هي حرب اغلبها
اغلب المشاركين فيها مسيحيين ان كان روسيا
او فرنسا او بريطانيا او النمسا لكن
المانيا طلبت من السلطه العثمانيه ان تعلن
ان هذه الحرب هي نوع من انواع الجهات في
سبيل الله فكان التاريخ يعيد نفسه استاذ
ماهر في حرب روسيا واوكرانيا هل نجحت دعوه
الوزير الاوكراني
الى فتح ابواب التطوع والقتال التاريخ
على ذكر التاريخ واجتنا في الحرب العالميه
في الحرب العالميه الثانيه هناك كتيبه من
الاخوان المسلمين قاتلت مع هتلر هذا موجود
على ذكر التاريخ ايضا احيل سيادتك الى
كتاب صدر عام 2021
شجرات من تاريخ القاعده لابو خبيب
بالسوداني وهو من قيادات التنظيم وهو لا
زال على قيد الحياه موجود في اليمن هذا
القياده موجود في اليمن وقال انه استازن
ناصر الوحيشي الرجل الثاني في تنظيم
القاعده قبل مقتله
لكتابه هذه الشجرات التاريخيه المهمه جدا
في هذا الكتاب يذكر كيف تعاون اسامه بن
لادن والتنظيم في بدايه نشاته مع الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه على ذكر التعاون مع
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه او القتال في
صف الولايات المتحده لا مشكله لدى هذه
التنظيمات ان تقاتل في الصف الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه او الغرب
طالما ان ذلك سوف ينهك ينهك الروس او ينهك
وهم ينظرون الى هذه الحرب انها سوف تنهك
الطرفين ثم تعطيهم فرصه مثاليه للتدريب
وللتسلح وللبقاء وللوجود وللقتال هذه فرصه
غير مسبوقه كما كان يتحدث حتى في بدايه
ثورات الربيع العربي يقول انها الثورات
هذه فرصه غير مسبوقه ستعطينا فرصه للحرب
داخل المنطقه هذا ما يحدث من هذا
التنظيمات كان لدي مشكله
نعم ليس لديهم مشكله في التعامل مع القوه
الغربيه على اي تبرير ارادوه لكن هذا ما
قالوه او هذا ما فكروا به او هذا ما املوه
قبل عام الان مر عام
اذا تاذن للاستاذ نجيب سنتوقف لفاصل ليس
لعام
وقت وجيز ثم نعود لنناقش هذه النقطه هل
صحت رهاناتهم التي رهنوا عليها قبل عام
فانتظرونا لوقت وجيز لنكمل هذا النقاش
فنحن في خضم امور
احار فيها اللبيب
[موسيقى]
اهلا وسهلا بكم من جديد نقاشنا عن مرور
عام على الحرب في بين روسيا واوكرانيا او
على المساحه الاوكرانيه بين روسيا والغرب
في الحقيقه
ونناقش نقطه محدده جدا الجماعات ذات
الطابع المسلح الجماعات الاصوليه يعني
الجماعات الجهاديه المسماه بالجماعات
الجهاديه
دعت قبل عام الى استغلال هذه الساحه
لاسباب متعدده عدم الانتقام من روسيا فرصه
للتدريب كما قال ضيوفنا الى اخر هذه
الاسباب هذا قبل عام بعد عام هل نجح هذا
الرهان
يناقش هذا الامر او نتناقش في هذا الامر
مع ضيوفنا هنا في الاستوديو الباحث اليمني
في الشؤون السياسيه الاستاذ نجيب غلاب
وعبر الاقمار الصناعيه من القاهره الاستاذ
ماهر فرغلي الذي هو ايضا مهتم بهذا
الحركات وله ابحاث خاصه حول موضوع الساحه
الروسيه الاوكرانيه وتواجد وعلاقه
الجهادين بها استاذ ماهر استوقفت قبل
الفاصل انهم هكذا راهنوا مثل ما ذكرت في
ورقتك راهنوا على الساحه الاوكرانيه لخلق
بؤره توتر جديده فرصه للتدريب فرصه
للانتقام من روسيا فرصه لبعض المقاتلين
للعوده الى الى بلاد بالذات المقاتلين
الشيشان والجمهوريات
لروسيا هكذا راهنوا هل نجح الرهان
قبل ان نجيب على هذا السؤال لدي يعني شيء
مهم لابد ان اشير اليه الشيء الاول ان ان
من لهجت التنظيمات الموجوده في سوريا
القريبه بالقوقاز بشكل عام وهذه
الجمهوريات
لديها مشكله ولابد ان تنتقل الى ساحه قتال
غرفه فيسبوك التي شكلوها واجهتها جبهه
التحرير الشام وردت تفكيكها ومن ثم هم
يريدون الانتقال الى مكان جديد طيب اذا
ايران في المعادله يعني ايران موجوده في
المعادله نحن نعلم ان قياده التنظيم
القاعده الرئيسيه الان سواء سيف العدل
وكان من قبل محمد المصري وغيره من قراءه
التنظيم موجودين في طهران يعني
ويعني وهو يتمتعون بحمايه كبيره جدا من
الدوله الايرانيه منذ فتره طويله وفق
اتفاقيه معروفه في وساق ابو ثبات والموضوع
هذا طرق بحثا بشكل كبير جدا اذا لا مشكله
وايران هي الداعم ولديها دعم مؤسف وكبير
جدا جدا للروس في هذه الحرب اذن لا مشكله
لدى تنظيم القاعده ولا لدي ايران في
التعاون ونقل المقاتلين الى الجبهه الى
الجبهه الاوكرانيه طب اذا هل نجح هذا
الرهان هناك على الناحيه الاخرى نفس
الرهان في الروس الاسلام السياسي نحن نعلم
رئيس الشيشاني يشكل كتابه ايضا وبسم
الاسلام ايضا وراينا فيديوهات قصيره لهذه
المسائل الكل اذا الحشد الديني موجود
الحشد الاسلامي موجود سواء حتى الحركات
هناك حركات الصوفيه او الناحيه الاخرى هي
طيارات اسلام سياسي متشدده في الناحيه
الاوكرانيه الى ان هناك جن ما يسمى بجده
الشام واماره القوقاز الاسلاميه وغيرها من
هذا التنظيمات موجوده
انا اريد اسال بشكل مباشر ومحدد استاذ
ماهر اليوم ونحن نتحدث في عام 2023 على
بدايه شهر مارس هل يوجد مجاميع وكتائب بين
قوسين جهاديه في اوكرانيا سؤال مباشر
نعم بكل تاكيد موجوده هناك تقرير الغربيه
يتحدث عن ذلك وهزم منشور في اكثر من موقع
ومنشوره اسماء هذه الكتائب وموجودين
يقاتلوا لم يحققوا نجاحات تذكر كما حققوا
في افغانستان او في بعض المناطق الاخرى في
الصومال وغيرها لكنهم موجودين باعداد
محدوده لو استمرت الحرب بهذا الشكل اتوقع
واعتقد ان اعدادهم ستزيد هل هم عرب ام من
مسلمي روسيا
لقى الغالبيه الكبرى هي من مسلم روسيا
والجمهورياتكستان
وبعض منهم كانوا يتبعون منظمه الرائد
الاسلاميه وهي منظمه اخوانيه موجوده في
اوكرانيا او تدير التنظيم الدولي للاخوان
في هذه المنطقه يعني شيشان
يقاتلون شيشان على الجبهتين وكلهم بدعوى
الجهات
نعم هذا ما يحدث الان الشيشانيين يشكلون
كتائب بقياده رئيس الشيشان ويقاتلون
ببساله وشجاعه مع الروس وعلى الناحيه
الاخرى الشيشانيون اخرون يقاتلون في
الجبهه الاوكرانيه باسم الاسلام ايضا
لانهاء الروس والانتقام
يعني عمليه السقر القديمه من روسيا لاسباب
تاريخيه واسباب سياسيه انا انا
دائما يحضرني في هذا الاطار التاريخ لاني
فعلا للمقوله ان التاريخ يكرر نفسها
احيانا صحيحه ويحضرنا في اطار شعري حركه
من حركات الخوارج في العهد
اعتقد بدايه العهد العباسي خرج رجل من
الخوارج من من قبائل بكر بن وائل
فخرج لقتاله رجل من قاده الدوله العباسيه
ايضا وائلي هذا المقتول الخارجي اسمه
الوليد بن طريف
والقائد العباسي اسمه يزيد بن مسجد
الشيباني الوائلي فانتصر جيش يزيد بن مسجد
الوائلي الشيباني على الوليد بن طريف
الخارجي الوائلي فقالت اخت الوليد ترفيهي
وائل يقتل بعضها بعضا لا يفل الحديد الا
الحديد فالشيشان كشان هؤلاء لا يفل الحديد
الا الحديد مفارقه استاذ نجيب كلها بدعوه
الجهاد هو صحيح حتى عندنا مثلا في الحاله
اليمنيه الان يعني من نفس المنطقه ومن نفس
العوائل يتقاتلوا فيما بينهم واللي مع
الشرعيه واللي مع الحوثيه لكن نحن نقاتل
باسم الدوله ايضا منظومه القاعده وهي الان
الكبرى هي يعني
باستثناء العناصر والخلايا المرتبطه
بالحوثيه يعني فاعلين نتيجه التخادم
الموجود بين الحوثيه والقاعده لكن ايضا في
الحرب يعني
الاوكرانيين الروسيه خرج مفتي مسلمي
اوكرانيا ولبس البزه العسكريه ايضا وافتى
انه قتال الروس من اوجب الواجبات وهذا
جهاد في سبيل الله ونفس الكلام مفتين
اخرين للمسلمين في الجانب الروسي افتوا
بنفس الفتوى
فالسرعه معقد هناك محاوله لتوظيف الاسلام
واستقطاب
مقاتلي ومسلمي الدولتين لصالح
دولهم لكن مساله استقطاب مقاتلين جهاديين
ارهابيين
ورغم في موجودين في اوروبا كثير لم يتم
استقطاب الجزء الكثير منهم
وهناك ناس مستعدين ايضا للذهاب الى
اوكرانيا
هناك حذر من استخدامهم بشكل مكثف لكن انا
اتفق معاه لو طالت الحرب
ممكن يتم توظيفها وهذا يقتضي انه وجود
الداعم ووجود ساحات الان وجود الداعم وجود
الدعم وجود التعبئه وتبنيه من قبل الدول
هذا المساله مش موجوده المساله الاهم انه
البيئه الحاضنه لمثل هذه الحركات داخل
اوكرانيا يعني وحتى عند الروس انا اعتقد
انها ضعيفه هي بيئه مختلفه يعني على مستوى
القوميه واللغه والدين وايضا جزء منهم
يعني رؤوا انها حرب بين الاطراف غير مسلمه
والمساله الاهم انه هناك تجربه حتى نقول
لدى الاسلام المعتدل خليك من القاعده
وداعش
بمساله ان يكون ان يتحولوا الى اعداء من
ادوات اداره الحروب البارده بين الغرب
والشرق وعندهم تجربه سابقه وخسروا وايضا
الغربيين ايضا مساله وايضا حتى العرب
والمسلمين مساله توظيف الجهاد في اداره
الصراعات بين الدول يتحول الى كارثه لاحقه
عليهم وعلى دولهم فالجميع حذر لكن
الاشكاليه اللي بيواجهها الغرب الان انه
كثير من المقاتلين اللي بيندفعوهم من
اليمين المتطرف وهذا يعني سيواجه الغرب في
الفتره القادمه مشكله من هؤلاء يندفعوا
للقتال تحت يعني الجيش الاوكراني وايضا
حتى
الروس ايضا خايف من مساله توظيف الخطاب
الديني بين المسلمين ان يرتد عليهم فهناك
حذر في هذه المساله من الاطراف المتجاتله
كدول روسيا واوكرانيا لكن هذا الحذر استاذ
ماهر ممكن تحته وطئه الحرب تعرف في الحب
والحرب كل شيء مباح كما يقال يعني تحت
وطاه الحرب قد يقال انه لا نستخدم هذا
السلاح النووي المعنوي الخطير وهو سلاح
الجهاد من الطرفين فهل نحن على مشارف هذا
الامر
وسؤالي المرتبط بهذا السؤال هل بقيت ساحه
مغريه للجماعات الجهاديه يعني هذه
الجماعات الجهاديه تريد ساحه تعمل فيها
القيود اللي موجوده الان في سوريا مع
الترتيبات اللي موجوده الان في يعني في
اليمن وغيره وكذا هل تصبح هذه الساحه هي
الساحه الامثل لهذه الحركات
بدات الغرب له يعني تجارب كثيره فيها في
دعم هذا الحركات والغرب لا مشكله لديه في
دعم هذه الحركات طالما يحقق المصلحه
واحيلك ايضا الى سيادتك الى مقال كتبه
مصطفى حامد ابو الوليد المصري في خلال هذا
الشهر على موقعي الالكتروني الذي يصدر
وبغرابه من طهران هذا الموقع يصدر وهذا
الرجل هو مؤرخ تنظيم القاعده له اكثر من
عشرين كتابا في التاريخ لتنظيم القاعده
كتب مقالا مهما للغايه خلال هذا الشهر عن
حرب الموانئ وحرب البحار واستدل بما يحدث
في اوكرانيا وقال ان الهجوم على
احدى المركبات او احدى السفن
الروسيه وتفجيرها هذا مهم جدا سوف يدفع
الروس للافراج عن صواريخ بحريه الى الينا
يعني سوف يدفع وهذه الصواريخ سوف تصل
الينا ومن ثم نحن لابد علينا ان ما يسمى
بحروب الموانئ وحروب البحار واول شيء واول
ساحه يمكن ان نستفيد من خلال الحرب
الاوكرانيه الروسيه هي الساحه اليمنيه
الصوماليه حيث هذه المنطقه منطقه بحريه
هامه يحدث لابد ان يحدث تبادل وتدريب هنا
ونقل الاسلحه والتدريبات من الحوشي الى
الصومال والعكس من الصومال الحسين الكلام
ما اقوله معنى كلامه لكن بالنص بالنص ما
قالوا مصطفى حامد يؤشر على كيفيه استاذ
ماهر لغير المتابع حضرتك متخصص تعريف فلو
بكلمتين عن مصطفى حامد من هو مصطفى حامد
بس عشان يعرفوا الناس قيمه كلام مصطفى
حامد
ام مصطفى حامد هو كان بدا عمله كصحفي كان
مراسلا لقناه
الجزيره انتقل الى افغانستان كمراسل انضم
الى جماعه سياف لفتره ثم عاد الى مصر ومصر
من محافظه الاسكندريه
عام 11 عاد الى مصر ثم عاد مره اخرى عمل
مستشار لسياف ثم عمل مستشارا لاسامه بن
لادن فتره طويله ثم عمل كمؤرخ لتنظيم
القاعده وله اكثر من 20 كتاب لتاريخ تنظيم
نعم وهو موجود وهو موجود في ايران موجود
في ايران حاليا موجود في طهران طيب هو شهر
سيف العدل يعني طيب سيف العدل القائد
الجديد تنظيم القاعده
باختصار نقطه خطيره يعني يقول لك انه ممكن
يستفيدون من الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه
ويعملون تطبيقات عليها في اليمن في
البلدات في حرب الموانع كما قال هو صحيح
يعني شوف بالذات الايرانيين يستفيدوا منه
من هذه الحقائق يستفيد من هذه الح فيما
يخص استخدام السلاح تهريبه
القاعده ستستفيد هناك تخادم ايضا في مساله
حتى حتى تهريب السلاح ما بين الحوثيين
والقاعده اكثر من يخدم
الحوثيه في تهريب السلاح هم القاعده سواء
في الصومال او على السواحل او في الداخل
اليمني وبالتالي هم يستفيدوا من يتخادموا
مع بعض
وهناك اموال تدفع للقاعده
من قبل من قبل الحوثيه نعم على كل حال
يعني اعتقد ان المياه المستطرقه يفضي
بعضها الى بعض ويتدفق وبعضها الى بعض حوثي
قاعده
حركات شيشانيه يمين مسيحي والضحيه في
النهايه هم الناس الاسيويه الذين يريدون
مستقبلا مشرقا وطبيعيا كبقيه ناجحين في
هذا العالم فحمانا الله ووقعنا اجمعين من
كل انواع الشرور يمينا او يسارا او الى
اللقاء
[موسيقى]